Nikhil Chandhok:
Okay, I'm going to talk about
two specific products over here,
one being AdSense video units.
It's a way to, uh--
It's a syndication
and monetization product
that we put approximately
six to eight months ago.
And it's essentially targeted
at web publishers,
who want to enhance their site
with monetized video.
And then I'm going to talk
about custom players,
which is another feature
of our site,
which is a way for people
to actually display playlists
on their site.
A lot of what we--
A lot of you are already used
to displaying embedded players,
like single clip embeds,
on your site.
But being able
to display a full playlist
lets you write a richer story,
add more context to your site.
So both of these are about--
These--
Both of these concepts are
focused on web masters,
web publishers, so to speak.
I know a lot of you guys
are API Developers.
But I still think it
will be useful for you
to understand all the--
all the syndication products
that YouTube provides.
And maybe you can leverage
some of these products
in an interesting way
within your
application source websites.
So Video Units--
why should you care?
It's a way
to enhance your site.
It's a way to enhance video,
add video to your site.
And you say,
"Yep, I can do that already."
I can pick a player on YouTube,
I can add it to my site.
And you know, the video plays,
I write a blog,
and I can add some text
around the blog,
and it's a fantastic solution.
Well, what Video Units says,
lets you draw up
a piece of code on your site,
and it lets you
contextually target the video.
So, much like AdSense,
where AdSense is able
to sense the page, and
figure out what is on the page,
Video Units is able to figure
out what is on the page,
figure out the relevant video
in our index
that can be showed
against that page.
And then what are the ads
against that page?
What are the ads
against the video and the page?
And serve them all together
in one package solution,
which we'll walk through
right after this.
So, it's about contextual video.
And the last thing--the most
important thing, I think--
A lot of people
have asked me this question
is, "How do you derive revenue?"
It's our first monetization
product that we've put out
as part of YouTube syndication.
So it's a way for you to derive
revenues from the video itself,
instead of--instead of deriving
revenue from the overall site
that you're building,
using the video, okay?
And feel free to stop me
at any time with any questions,
or clarifications that--
Can everybody hear me okay?
Yep.
Okay.
So how does it--
What does it mean?
So, normally
when you see a video on YouTube,
it has--this is an example
of an Audi A4 video on YouTube.
It's got it's little--
it's playing on YouTube.
And it's got this little
embedded player
that you guys are used
to seeing.
The Adsense Video Units
player
is actually a different kind
of player.
And you see this player--
If you look at the player,
it has a banner ad on the top.
And the video is
still playing inside the player.
And there is an in stream ad
on top of that.
And what happens is--
And the concept is essentially
this player gets syndicated
from YouTube,
and then ends up on a
publisher's site,
where the publisher
is then syndicating the video
for YouTube.
It is enhancing
the publisher's site,
and also the publisher
is participating
in a three-way revenue share.
So the way it work is,
the content--
the only content we can monetize
is the content that comes
from YouTube partners.
So it is not all the content
in the YouTube index,
it's a section of that content
that we have verified
who the owner is,
and now we can run ads
against this content.
So there's one big difference
around what content can flow on.
The content is bundled with ads.
So right here,
if you see up there,
there's an ad unit that goes
with the content.
It's not just a standard
embedded player,
where there is no ads;
the ads travel with the player.
And the last part being,
it's a three-way revenue share.
And you might ask,
"Who are the three parties
in the revenue share?"
Well, it's yourself,
who's the publisher,
it's Google,
and it's the content-owner,
who is actually
giving us the content,
and is--has not been
participating in the value chain
so far, but it's our way
for help them make--
help them make some money.
So that more, and more good
content can flow in the system.
And everybody
in the ecosystem
can then derive the benefits
of syndication.
Any questions on this line?
Yeah?
man:
Is it ever a two-way revenue
share where you don't have--
It's, like, maybe a popular
video, but it's [indistinct].
I show it on my site,
I split it with Google,
but that person never
sends it down.
Chandhok:
Yeah.
No, we cannot do that.
Because I mean, the value has
been derived from the playback.
And, um...
The lawyers would argue
that most of the value
has been derived
from the playback,
and we have to make sure
that we know who the owner is
before running an ad
on the--on the video.
man:
Thank you.
Chandhok:
Sure.
man:
Does the video--you mention
that it's sort
of contextually targeted,
does the video actually change
based on what text is
on the screen?
Chandhok:
Yep, it will change based on
what text is on the page.
It'll change automatically.
It'll change based on--as
new content comes in our index,
we try to keep the videos
as fresh as possible.
So the idea there is not just
about deriving revenue, right.
Traditionally AdSense publishers
have looked at all AdSense units
as a way to derive revenue,
and this is a way to deri--
to drive engagement
in an automated fashion.
So I have a car blog,
and I put up this.
One day it might be
an Audi video that shows up,
another day it might be
a Honda video that shows up,
but the idea there is
that we can show you
fresh and relevant content
at all times.
man:
Okay, just as a follow-up,
so how is that relevant?
Is it sort of calculated?
Is it based on the words?
Chandhok:
Yeah.
Uh no, the relevance is--
So we get meta data associated
with the video,
that comes in with the video.
And we max that meta data.
We have
a traditional AdSense servers
that are figuring out
what ads to run on the page.
Those same AdSense servers
are figuring out
what category the page is in.
So they figure out,
"Oh, this is a car page,
"so we need to go look into--
go look for a car video."
And then we have algorithms
in the back that figure out,
"Okay, what's a popular car
video that monetizes well?"
That's going to be relevant
to this page.
And then we serve it up.
When multiple signals going into
it, for like, the elements,
freshness, um, child safety--
all those things.
Because we want to make sure
that what we are syndicating
is more or less safe.
man:
So there's a basic piece
of the meta data there
is captured during upload,
right?
Chandhok:
Yeah, it's captured
on the video site.
Yeah, on the video site
it's captured during upload.
But then again,
it's matched against the page.
So we don't go into the spoken
word of the video, you're right.
Okay?
man #2:
Can I ask a question?
Chandhok:
Sure.
man #2:
So on an international page,
do you have to take the content
of the page
and send it back to Google?
Chandhok:
No, I mean,
Google will crawl it.
If your participating
in AdSense,
Google is automati--whenever
you sign up for AdSense,
you take a domain,
and you give it to AdSense.
And you say, "Hey, I'm going
to run ads on this page."
The way AdSense works,
is it comes--
the crawlers come out,
they figure out the page,
and then we pick up
the signals from the page.
And um...
we target the video on the page.
Sure.
man #3:
So you're running basically,
a targeted video advertisement
and a contextual advertisement
on top of it?
Chandhok:
It's video content,
plus textual advertising.
man #3:
That means that content is going
to be provided by the people
who are syndicating it
on purpose.
So for instance, if I had a car
on my page that had video,
it's probably being presented
by the manufacturer.
Chandhok:
No, no, no.
It's a lot of our partners,
our regular partners,
we have very big partners.
I--Off the top of my head,
I don't know.
So all our...
like, Lisa Nova, and Smosh--
All of them are participating
in the program.
So you
have entertainment content,
you have car content of course,
coming from car magazines.
I'd like to say TalkGear
is a partner,
but I don't remember if the BBC
is partnering with us on this.
And we have a bunch of content
that is not advertorial.
So a goal of this content
is not advertorial content,
it is actually content
that is engaging and useful
to a user who is coming
on the site.
And oh, by the way, the content,
it's high-value content,
and the cost--typically you
would pay to syndicate.
As a publisher, you would pay
the owner of the content rights,
to actually get the content
on your site.
In this case, we are saying,
"We'll support it with that.
"It comes bundled.
"And the cost to you,
publisher, is nothing."
Okay?
Last question.
I got to move on to--
man #4:
So is it possible that you could
be talking about content
for, say, a BMW car.
Chandhok:
Yeah.
man #4:
And starting off an Audi ad.
Chandhok:
Uh, it could be an Audi--
depends, I don't know.
Hopefully, our systems
are not that stupid.
[laughing]
[man speaking indistinctly]
Chandhok:
Yeah, then you know,
it could pick up anything.
Yeah, I mean, it's going to pick
up--it'll key off the key words.
And that's just the challenge
of all contextual--
The classic example is Java.
Are you talking about Java,
the language,
or java, the coffee, right?
So...
[man speaking indistinctly
Chandhok:
Hopefully our Ad systems
are smarter than that.
Uh, what are the ad types?
There are two types of ads.
Clearly, there's ads on top.
Which can be banner,
or text ads.
So in the previous example, you
saw a text ad being on the top.
In this example, I have a banner
ad, which is a 468 by 60 unit,
bundled with a video on the top.
It can be CPC text
and image ads.
It can be CP image ad
on the top.
In Stream typically tends
to be a text ad or image ad,
but it tends to be a CPC ad.
Okay?
[short silence]
How do you configure this?
It's much like AdSense in the
sense that you drop a piece
of code on your site.
The code is generated for you.
You configure your player
using your AdSense account.
You are able to adjust the size
of the player.
You're able to pick up
multiple player formats.
If you look over here,
there are five player formats.
They're kind of small.
As I walk to the demo,
you'll see those.
And then the last,
and most interesting piece is
you are able to focus the video
choices using key words
and categories.
So if I have an auto blog,
and let's say we have
"Autos and Vehicles,"
as a category,
And then we have "News and
Ent"--"News" also as a category.
So lets say I don't want
any news content on my site.
All I want is like,
good quality auto content.
So what I'm going to do
is just uncheck the "News" box.
I'm going
to uncheck the "Humor" box.
I don't want anything funny
about cars on my site.
So all I want is something
about "Autos and Vehicles,"
and all I want is that.
If I'm not
an "Autos and Vehicles" site,
if I'm an "Entertainment" site,
all I want it entertainment,
I'm gonna choose that.
I'm going to start
getting the Smosh videos,
the Lisa Nova videos,
whatever else has
been syndicated in our index.
If I just choose "News,"
I'm going to start
getting everything
that's being syndicated
by the local stations
on my site, right?
So it's a combination of--
it gives you enough--
You can choose all categories.
You can choose two categories.
You can choose three categories.
It's up to you.
And then you can use keywords
to further inform us
on how to do--on how
to optimize the targeting.
Okay.
Where do I--Where do you
go see your revenue in AdSense?
Within Adsense, there is the
concept of AdSense for content.
And within that, if you use--
if you are using AdSense ads
on your site today, it's
called "AdSense For Content."
There's a channel
that gets created within that.
It's called, "Video Units."
And you start seeing
your revenue flow through that.
Okay?
So this is pretty simple,
and once you drop it,
the channel
gets created automatically.
You sign up for it.
Everything just starts flowing
into that.
[short pause]
Uh, demo.
So I'm gonna
quickly walk through
what it means to do this.
And so I'm--
This is my AdSense account.
I've already logged into
my AdSense account.
And if I go into AdSense Setup,
which is their second tab,
I can--I can then
see AdSense for Content,
which is the typical ads
that you drop on your site.
AdSense for Search, Referrals,
which we are retiring,
and then Video Units is the
fourth unit that was put out.
And now we have
AdSense for Mobile Content.
So when I click on Video Units,
that just takes me
to my YouTube account.
So prior to this, uh--
Prior to this talk,
I've gone ahead and linked
my AdSense account
and my YouTube account.
And the reason
we have to link those accounts
is YouTube was an acquisition,
and they still haven't
migrated all our YouTube
accounts to Google accounts.
Once we are done
with the migration of accounts,
it should be
a one-click process,
and hopefully you don't have to
associate those two accounts.
So for now,
you have to associate--
You have to go through the pain
of associating those accounts.
And then I can create
an AdSense Player.
And I can say, well--
"My car player."
Can pick a color.
And so I pick blue.
I'm gonna use
an expandable unit,
which is a 728x90 unit,
which is a standard
IB size unit.
We have three units
which are not expandable.
The 400x415, 500x510
which are more focused on--
which are full-size units
in the sense that they
are not IB standard units.
There is no standard
IB video player size yet,
so what we tried to do
was create expandable units
that fit within
existing inventory
that publishers would have.
So 728x90 and 160x600.
This is the other unit we have.
It's a 160x600 unit.
It's a vertical unit
which shows
a bunch of thumbnails,
and then you can
click on a thumbnail
and it expands
into the playback experience.
I can choose my content,
so I'm gonna
choose Autos & Vehicles,
and I'm going to
unselect everything else.
We have bunch
of categories here.
If it's a pet site,
you can put pet content.
Gaming.
We have a lot
of gaming content coming in
after Spore was launched.
A lot of people uploading
a lot of Spore content.
All of that gets monetized
really, really well.
And then I'm gonna
say Generate Code.
And so my player was created.
And this is the code
for the player.
I accidentally created
a vertical player,
but all what I have
embedded in my blog
is a horizontal player,
so I'm gonna show you that.
So if I go here on Blogger,
where I've actually
embedded the player--
It's a player about cars.
And I'm able to scroll through
multiple videos over here.
And I'm able to play
this video right here.
Right, so this is a car video
that got syndicated through us
by one of our--
It's a video about--
classified as Autos & Vehicles
that got syndicated to us
by one of our partners.
On this one,
you're seeing a banner ad,
which is of text,
and then in-stream ad,
which is also around text.
And you get paid every time
a user clicks on an ad,
so if I click on this ad--
User is taken off the site
and at that point
there's a publisher payout event
that happened.
So at this point I can
play another video.
I can skip through videos.
If I went back here,
and I went back to this--
Sorry.
I think I lost...
I could actually change
the category of the content.
Right there, from...
Instead of Autos & Vehicles,
I could choose Film & Animation.
Save the player.
And if I went back here,
and refresh this page,
I have different content now,
showing up in the player.
So again--so if you have
a network of sites
that you're managing,
it's the same piece--
you're creating one player.
And you had,
depending on if you have
a class of websites
that you're managing,
all you'd--you have one central
console to manage your players,
and then all this
monetized content
being distributed on that site.
So again, over here,
this is entertainment.
Also, we chose Film & Animation.
So I don't know what this is,
but it's funny.
Okay. Any questions on this?
I have seven--
how many more minutes?
Seven.
[chuckles]
Sure, uh, black. In the black.
woman: Could you
repeat what you said
concerning having
a YouTube account
and, like, an AdSense--
if you have--
I have an AdSense account.
Chandhok: Yeah.
woman: So what do I have to do?
Chandhok: So you--when you
go inside AdSense,
you just click on...
I'll show you.
It's gonna log me in.
You go to AdSense Setup.
And click on this link.
Click on Video Units.
And it'll walk you through
linking of the accounts.
Okay?
woman: That will take care
of your YouTube--
Chandhok: Yeah. It'll walk you
through how to do that.
Is there another question?
Yeah.
man: I'm still trying
to understand how to see--
where three-way revenue
is gonna be going.
Chandhok: Sure.
The three-way revenue share
is essentially
between yourself the publisher,
the content owner, and Google.
Does that make sense?
man: But who's paying?
Chandhok: Who is paying?
The advertiser is paying.
It's ad supported.
So when the ad runs,
somebody clicks on the ad
or there's an
impression of the ad,
the advertiser is--
Advertiser is paying
to advertise on that content
and on your site.
And when a click
happens on the ad,
revenue is generated, and then
that revenue from that ad
is spread between
the three people
who are participating
in the syndication.
man: So I have to have
a content platform,
and I can Google Survey the ads.
Chandhok: Yep.
man: Somebody providing
some content or information.
Chandhok: Yep.
man: And in order
to get to see that content,
I have to watch it there.
Chandhok: Yep. It's the cost
of the content.
When you watch cable television,
you are paying Comcast money
per month to watch television.
On this, it's ad supported.
Right? So.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Chandhok: We try to optimize
for the highest rpm on that one.
Yeah.
man: You mentioned that
sport content modifies as well.
Chandhok: Yeah.
man: In that case, who do you
consider the content owner?
Is it the guy who uploaded
that custom video?
Or is it support?
Chandhok: Uh, it's EA.
Because the sport is different,
because it is--
It was created
within the environment,
the EA environment.
So EA actually owns the content.
man: Even though it's user--
Chandhok: Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Yep?
man: Do you plan on allowing
any further custom relation
of the YouTube--
[man speaking indistinctly]
Do you plan on
allowing more fine tuning?
Chandhok: Yep.
So we are looking
into providing more, like,
different more formats,
which are more flexible.
Last question; I gotta finish
one other part
of the presentation.
man: Since you mentioned
that the videos
can only be monetized with
a deal with the content creator,
do you have an idea
of percentage-wise
what you see now, and what
you kind of expect to see,
in terms of video served,
as to which--
how many videos are monetized?
Are we talking, like, 1-2% now,
maybe growing to 10
by the end of the year?
Chandhok: I can't give
exact numbers, but in absolute--
I can't give exact
percentages of, like,
how much of the corpus
is monetizable,
but in absolute numbers of,
like, con--
We are the largest
cleared content depository
on the internet.
And I can make that claim.
It's large enough that you
will not run out of content.
That's what I'm gonna say.
Okay?
I don't have
a good answer to that
because then I'd be giving
private information.
Okay, there's one other
thing I wanna share.
I'm gonna do it very quickly.
So what we just discussed
was about video,
and it was about
building contextually--
bringing context--
[clears throat]
Sorry.
Bringing contextually targeted
video to your site
and have it supported by ads,
and then deriving
revenue from that.
We have another
feature on our site,
which we call Custom Players,
which is a simple way
for you to embed playlists
on your site.
So everybody's familiar
with embedding single players,
but not a lot of people know
how to embed playlists
on their site.
Again, we have multiple
player formats here.
We have a full page player
with thumbnails along with that,
and then we have
a smaller player,
which kind of cycles
through the playlist.
You can display any
YouTube playlist through this.
It is not limited
like video units.
Because there is
no monetization, right?
So all the content in the index
is available to syndicate,
and again, much like the--
the demo you just saw,
you can change
the playlist on the fly,
and the players
update everywhere.
So it's a very
simple thing to use.
How do you configure it?
Again, you do it
through your account.
It's--You choose your videos,
you choose your player,
you choose--you choose
the colors of the player,
and then you choose the playlist
you want to embed in.
So I'm going to
quickly demo this
because I have two more minutes.
So if I go to my account,
I click on Account.
I can go to what is called
Custom Video Players.
And I can create
a custom player.
So, this one I'm going to
call Spore Videos.
Make it pink.
I'm gonna choose
the small one over here.
This is a playlist
I created in the past
when we launched the Spore--
when we launched Spore
a couple of weeks ago.
It's a bunch of Spore videos.
And then I'm going to
say Select.
Generate code.
Go to Blogger.
Make a new post.
So now I'm gonna be able to play
my Spore videos right there.
So you can see the little--
what we like to call
the Genie pop up
with all the videos over here.
[video's music playing quietly]
I can skip through videos.
I mean, I can watch these
for hours, but...
[audience laughs]
man: Is it, like,
an automatic--
Chandhok: Yeah, it automatically
cycles through, and, like, uh...
And if you go back--
I can go back and make this
a Joe Biden playlist,
if I wanted to.
It's all controlled
from the back.
Sorry, go ahead.
There's a question.
man: Most of this is
from a different paced
current generated...
I know you guys have
a subset player
for industry
password combinations
for a popular drawing platform
and other services.
Is there a philosophy on that
on how to do the syndication
if I mail stuff,
can I paste in that code,
or it could be
supported in more other
subscription files
that are more automatic.
Chandhok: We want to get
as automatic as possible,
so, I mean, the way--
The direction
I want to move in is
all of this
is programmable to an API.
So any platform, like,
if you have word press,
or automatic out there,
using our APIs
and embedding the players.
I mean, the more--We have no--
I think if you're not sensitive
to one channel or the other.
Right? So any channel
that works is good for us.
man: The biggest
alteration you might make
is if in the future, especially
if it optimizes the platform--
Chandhok: Yep.
man: Somebody walked in--
[man speaking indistinctly]
--walked into
a lot of their own files.
Do you get more--
Chandhok: Yeah, so this player
actually then has to become
an open social gadget;
it has to become smarter.
Right now, it doesn't know
how to talk to the container.
man: It might be cool,
if you go
in that direction
with the actual--
you have to have syndication...
[man speaking indistinctly]
Chandhok: Yeah. Yeah. I mean...
It's a good idea.
[chuckles]
I should do it.
[audience laughs]
[man speaks indistinctly]
[Chandhok laughs]
Um, I mean, I can't say--
You might be
the first person to think of it.
It's all--We're always
looking for feedback.
So, well, I mean, we are
constantly evolving the player.
I know that the player
is dumb today.
So, but it runs
on MySpace, right,
so, it's got--
it's a Flash Player,
it runs on MySpace.
All the pages on MySpace
are not really container pages.
There's this
little container section,
and that's not really
flexible enough for us to, like,
move the player.
I mean, we would like to have
a smarter version of the player,
it's just not enough
container pages out there.
man: You're saying that
the content index, like,
makes it a much higher bar
for the average person...
Chandhok: Yeah.
It does, it does.
Anything else?
Yeah.
man: Is there a way to show--
for the videos that are
playing in the playlist,
is there a way to show the title
and descriptions as they play?
Chandhok: Um, no,
but we should--
Hopefully we put out an API
which lets you query the player,
and then you can
manage that yourself.
[coughs]
Any other questions?
Okay. Thank you.
[applause]